.
ALL OF O'ROURKE'S CAMPAIGN
EVENTS HAVE BEEN POSTPONED UNTIL
HE RECOVERS.
RECENT POLLS SHOWING HIM TRAILER
GOVERNOR ABBOTT BY 7 POINTS.
>>> SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM
RAISING EYEBROWS WITH THESE
COMMENTS FOLLOWING THE FBI'S
RETRIEVAL OF AT LEAST 184
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS FROM
MAR-A-LAGO.
>> IF THERE'S A PROSECUTION OF
DONALD TRUMP FOR MISHANDLING
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION AFTER THE
CLINTON DEBACLE WHICH YOU
PRESIDED OVER AND DID A HELL OF
A GOOD JOB THERE WILL BE RIOTS
IN THE STREETS.
>> JOINING US NOW OLIVIA NUTSY
AND OLIVIA HOWELL.
HOW SHOULD LINDSEY GRAHAM READ
WHAT HE SAID RIGHT NOW?
>> DID HE LIVE THROUGHOUT THE
RESURRECTION.
I DIDN'T THINK HE WAS OVERLY
CONCERNED ABOUT POLITICAL
VIOLENCE OVER THE WAKE OF THAT
OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS THAT HE
HAS BEEN DEFENDING THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
I THINK IT IS AN ATTEMPT TO FEAR
MONGER AND IT'S NOT ALL THAT
SURPRISING GIVEN HOW LINDSEY
GRAHAM HAS KIND OF DONE
EVERYTHING AND SAID ANYTHING
THAT HE COULD THINK OF TO TRY TO
SUPPORT THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
IT'S AS IF THE INSURRECTION DID
NOT HAPPEN TO SAY THAT AS IF --
AS IF SOMETHING LIKE THAT HAS
NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE AND IT
WOULD BE COMPLETELY
UNPRECEDENTED FOR THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S SUPPORTERS TO DO
THAT SOUNDS PRETTY RIDICULOUS.
>> EMILY.
>> I DO HOPE THAT SENATOR GRAHAM
UNDERSTANDS THE WEIGHT OF HIS
WORDS.
HE SEEMS TO BE SIMULTANEOUSLY
INDICATING THAT HE BELIEVES THE
FORMER PRESIDENT TO BE ABOVE THE
LAW BUT ALSO POTENTIALLY
INCITING VIOLENCE.
THIS IS THE SAY LINDSEY GRAHAM
WHO THE DAY AFTER THERE WAS
INSURRECTION AT THE CAPITOL ON
JANUARY 6 SAID COUNT ME OUT,
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
ALSO THE SAME LINDSEY GRAHAM WHO
IS TRYING TO RESIST THE GRAND
JURY PROBE INTO POTENTIA